the Democratic National Convention is  officially underway and night two did  not disappoint  thanks to funny speeches heartfelt  tributes and even a celebrity-filled  musical moment all in support of  Democratic presidential nominee Hillary  Clinton actresses Lena Dunham and  America Ferrera started their speech  with a bit of humor I'm Lena Dunham and  according to Donald Trump my body is  probably like a - and I'm America  Ferrera and according to Donald Trump  I'm probably a rapist  Hillary's husband former President Bill  Clinton got nostalgic retelling the  couple's love story and praised his  wife's intelligence and tenacity this  time Hillary is uniquely qualified to  seize the opportunities and reduce the  risk we face and she is still the best  darn change maker I have ever known and  the crowd really went wild for this  celebrities like Jane Fonda Connie  Britton Eva Longoria and SIA  all singing rachel platten 'he's hit  fight song of course for Hillary  Hilary